on va accueillir nos deux invités du
soir c'est un événement assez vrai que
depuis des semaines et des semaines on
me dit il vient quand il vient quand il
vient quand on est bien ici ce soir
booba est avec nous et il s'occupe des
vieux qui jouent bas parce que booba ont
la classe et effet comme s'il avait
marqué un but je remercie les gars seria
gfm commence à vraiment bas c'est la
deuxième fois que vous venez nous voir
ça veut dire que vous nous avez bien
ouais ouais dont j'aime bien c'est vrai
merci ça me fait plaisir je le connais
pas et en plus tous les deux on a on a
un point commun c'est à dire vous avez
de nombreux clashs et moi aussi
c'est vrai qu'on déclenche en commun je
crois ouais il y avait pas dire qu'il ya
dix ans joey starr on a en commun
voilà on a également passé tout à part
ça moi j'ai hélène rollès vous lie à la
fouine ya rohff yaakaar initiale en
classe avec la foule c'est fini
maintenant je suis pas au clash avec la
fouine et j'aime bien il va nous voir
c'est parfois ça va mieux que la fouine
ou pas ça va aller mieux je sais pas ce
qu'il devient non mais
et ça me fait de la peine que vous soyez
en brouille avec la fouine parce que
j'aime beaucoup
comme je vous aime bien les deux ça me
fait chier franchement c'est vrai après
l'opus il a dit du bien de vous la
dernière fois on remettra je crois non
non franchement je suis pas très bien
les gens je me suis couché comme ça je
me dis ça mais un peu c'est un peu relou
et booba booba contre mathieu delormeau
booba voici ton poids matthieu delormeau
attention vous devez rester quoi ton
record bras tendu comme ça encore il
s'appelle rohff bras tendus
[Applaudissements]
et
ouais ouais ou encore chaud et va t elle
mais fondamentale est débile
attention bras tendus celui qui restera
le plus longtemps
booba face à mathieu delambre déjà je
rappelle quand même l'album de booba qui
fait un carton vous bat on n'avait pas
besoin de le rappeler c'est un carton
merci d'avoir été avec nouba j'espère
que vous allez gagner sinon c'est casser
la tête pendant six ans il me donne mon
docteur c'est possible j'en avais la
lada et y perdra jamais attention à ce
que vous pouvez pour s'entraîner mais ce
coffret vous sent très souple et même si
l'on bat sco beau et bien là près de lui
attention c'est parti
bras tendus a donné partie 3-2 à top
lolo voit plus au bureau le bras euro le
bras c'est lourd un peu c'est bon ça va
ou pas tu me dis sinon façon presque
concentré d'accord j'arrête de chercher
un texto en même temps c'est moi je veux
que tu saches que je vais faire booba
continue je vais ranger mes petites
affaires
c'est la fin de l'émission vous faites
votre coin sont rendus mais bon dieu
aime les petites heures ça va on est là
domaniale yvan attal d'ailleurs qui sera
dans l'émission demain également
joignent aura des mots clairs de la
télévision aussi booba voilà je vous
donne un petit peu ce cas demain parce
que c'est important de le dire
juste après je retiens un film c'est
quoi le film en régie reprennent rocha
war iii ça va faire un carton que ça la
formule plaît pas vu non et baboo ainsi
si l'on parle des fusées
on va voir qui gagnent entre booba et
matthieu delormeau un joueur de moins
souffrir bienne et la chaux je suis une
structure de l'ordre n'est pas bien on
fera
allez les gars son mental
[Applaudissements]